[Music]  i'm trace gallagher and i've been at fox  news channel for 25 years i remember  having this conversation with a guy who  wrote an article in the early years of  fox news channel and he referred to  people as the cable cowboys he said you  guys are doing things that nobody's ever  done they have so far uncovered some 30  explosive devices you would do this live  shot and you would take people on this  tour but network television had never  seen any of this stuff and you can see  he's at speeds now of upwards of 110  miles we got great at breaking news and  it was just this kind of amazing drama  that nobody ever put on television  before and it was one of those things  where  there were no rules and we prayed and  crossed our fingers for breaking news  because it would fill air time and  people loved it that was groundbreaking  they'd never done it before and now  you think love us or hate us it has  become this cultural phenomenon  [Music]  you